[Music]
the white time yes
yes you can
see leave your memes on the reddit 19
year old
and i'll measure your peeps in the next
episode
first of all
i need to apologize a sincere apology
i really mean it with my true emotions
we're getting a good shot of this
okay guys it looks like i'm actually
crying this is very effective
how about that youtubers that's so
that's how they do it
i did actually want to make a genuine
apology uh
ignore the tears i kind of snapped
yesterday at the live stream
towards my fans and i didn't like how i
did that i was getting hyped to play the
goddamn game i was so hyped to play it
and as soon as we started people saw my
psn and they started spamming me and
notifications show up show up and
i hate getting interrupted especially if
i'm ready to do something and i kind of
just told people a [ __ ] off and i'm
sorry
i asked if they had no friends and
what's wrong with you yeah a lot of
people say we're
like oh it's fine i would have gotten
pissed too but i didn't like how i
reacted
i never want to tell my fans to [ __ ] off
so
it doesn't seem like anyone's making a
big deal but i i didn't like the way i
acted about it i shouldn't have gone so
mad about i should have just laughed
about it
so i'm sorry
[Music]
i wouldn't be anywhere without you guys
where would i be without my audience i
did also say that we're not friends and
uh
it was a little harsh as well it's just
like why are you messaging me god damn
it i'm getting worked up again
like i don't mind talking to fans i like
doing that but
not when it's intruding on my own space
does that make sense oh he doesn't love
his fans he told him
no i told people that interrupt and go
through my
private stuff i don't know it's such a
thing where
constantly i i don't know why i'm making
this uh whole thing it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
why epic somewhere in the parallel
universe felix if finland never
invented the internet browser finland
i am so sorry i always talk better
finland where would i be i would be
nothing without you finland
i'm sorry comment aside
finland sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry okay
sorry finland aang has never seen such
bs before
huge some dragon ball it looks like
dragon ball god damn it what
why do you have to wear orange if it
ain't dragon ball they ripped off
a dragon ball aang vs water sheep
you know who would win you know god damn
well water sheep master water element
oh my god i was watching an official
session
of the european parliament and notice
that the member of the ua parliament
is using pewter's chair she is the
president
of the european pirate party well well
well
i have no idea what they stand for but i
approve
all their politics unless it's
anti-semitic or racist
or yeah that's it that's my only
requirements
oh my god we did it boys
she's wearing the jurgen match too
legend
wait it's a swedish civil libertarianism
internet freedom defend the freedom of
expression communication education
respect the privacy of citizens
okay epic befriend the free flow of
ideas knowledge culture we can
definitely use that
support politically the reform of
copyright and patent launch
epic open access open data epic
that's cool that's so cool
uh dare i say huge peepee we've been
tricked we've been backstabbed we've
been quite possibly bamboozled
my three-year-old was watching coco
melon in the intro i know where this is
going
and the intro got me excited because i
thought he was watching fans
why is it backfiring you dare use my own
spells against me
potter oh no what have we done
we were supposed to trick the
three-year-olds not the other way around
spend three hours making pixel art so
your idol knows
notices it gets featured in video for
one second
your idol says what the hell am i
looking at
no oh god
that was so rude i'm so sorry
that was so rude i thought it was a
reference like everything was references
so i
and it was cartoon i was like what the
hell is this i don't know this
i'm sorry i'm sorry i've been just
freaking up
left and right lately let's not forget
the biggest simp who killed the whole
universe for a woman
wait dinos is a simp that's why he did
it
oh what the dad oh
don't i can't like tunnels anymore it
was my favorite enemy
why can't i find a guy like this ugh hey
no he's literally god damn it
i know i would get so much for that god
damn it soon as i read the comments
it's all the comments is about sorry i
mistook your favorite anime character
all bald people look the same changed my
mind
can't change my mind by all means mary
if you get a good life you'll be happy
if you get a bad one you'll become a
philosopher
socrates stares [ __ ]
oh no no no well i guess he was wrong
huh
plus we don't know for sure what
socrates said or not
which is a very convenient thing to
bring up whenever you disagree with
something he said
well actually he never wrote down
anything so we don't
we can't really verify i posted this on
my in my members chat
socrates was ripped can't change my mind
besides it's a disgrace to grow old
through sheer carelessness before seeing
what matter of a man you may become by
developing your bodily strength
and beauty to their highest limit but
you cannot see that if you are
careless for it will not come on its own
accord socrates was ripped
confirmed i knew with rare footage of
floor gang general peacemaster64
initiating the war with ceiling gang
yeah i uh that was some crazy times i
remember shooting that
i shot that light and i think it's
halogen lights or something like that
it's really poisonous gas
do not break those lights don't be
me if my son ever gets 80 million
subscribers oh wow thanks dad i will
host meme review
that seems so legit that's totally my
dad yeah it's dead that's his handle
definitely okay we got another intro
very epic
look for your winnings son
i am always winning dad
nice crossover nunny
[Music]
well done well done now that's comedy
absolute win whoever made that the four
horsemen of simp
we actually respect excuse me
two pubes but his tambourine tower is so
big that my friend had to post the other
half
no no where is it
no you failed it was supposed to be
above
come on can we hit 106 million subs
tambourine needs to grow stronger oh
it's not strong enough
why 106 million subscribers
is that so much to ask i love my fans
we're best friends we're homies we're
bros
for remember i thought we were bros
i thought we were bros god dammit
i'm not crying anime when i'm alone
anime when mom wants it
nicer
i never cry in my life ever crying is
for
pansies and i don't need pants
[ __ ]
i don't use that [ __ ] we're saying ew
are you making fun of my apology i'm
trying to open up for you guys
do you not understand the bravery it
takes to open up in front of an audience
[Music]
so true even when i watch except my side
walks by periods about his tamarind
tower so big that my friend had to post
the other
well you failed mission failed we'll get
him next time periods filthy mongols
me a mongolian 19 year old i feel my
heart crack
sorry mongols sorry
[Laughter]
yes dad i'm eating banana for my live
stream
audience thanks for joining
bros an indian man traveled from india
to sweden on a bicycle
to meet his swedish wife in 1978 the
journey took him four months
through eight countries what a
simp my god very wholesome though very
nice
big peepee but man what a thing you know
you've been watching pewdiepie for too
long when this looks normal and this
doesn't that's right there's a new anime
character that looks identical to him
what is it called kite
there he is he's an estonian youtuber
the most overpowered character of all
time
wait so he's a he's a youtuber and he's
massively overpowered
character based by me i think yes yes
yes yes yes coincidence no no no no no
never forget when doof roasted all of
america without
even using an inator i was heading to a
golden land of opportunity
but i ended up in america instead
got him that's my doof and smurf right
there
are you editing cybe yes my lord
yes the video is almost done are you not
finished yet side
felix you should get one of these oh my
god
is there a pewdiepie titty anime matt
that would be weird no crude when he
gets assassinated i don't know never
played the game
creed oh nice got it it's an office joke
got it
see i watched the office you don't have
to tell me to watch it you don't have to
tell me to force them to watch it just
go ahead and get the record god damn it
god damn it game releases a free skin
people in the game
good meme girl
how tall are you guy i'm six foot
guys check this out link is in the
comments
no way i came from the future the bro
army has taken over the world and you
have a hundred million
subs no this is a rickroll
the time travelers they're on our side
where's the comment you know you can
link
commas right no there it is holy sh
it's real oh my god the prophecy
we have oracles on our side we have
oracles au
720 what does that mean we need to
decipher this
if he made it then we're all gonna make
it bros what the [ __ ]
this is freaking me out
what the hell mind you i had like 20 000
or 50 000 subs at this time dude
oh my god petition for pits to cover
this lasagna with tambourine
next video for sure entirely made out of
text took me three days
what oh whoa
you just never know what medium people
are going to use next
damn huge peepee very large
i wanted blippi huge finishing fair
pewds
oh no all right i'm watching avatar
the lights and urban the guides i'm
watching it now i'm
i'm so sorry for having seen avatar the
last airbender even though i watched it
as a kid
okay but nickelodeon scattered all the
episodes so i never understood what the
hell the story was
earth wind fire some [ __ ] then a guy
with a burn
patch on his eye that was a simp that's
all i remember
as pubs are opening in three days here's
a map of every pub in the uk
wait it's all pub always has been
always has been good meme it's been some
good memes recently
wait it's still relevant always has been
how dare you even question it don't
waste your diamonds on a hoe
captain sparkles true rewards had never
been spoken
if only josh knew if only josh knew
he wouldn't go to prison he didn't need
to take it that far one of
wanna if your friend is ever simping
just tell them like bro just
just play minecraft why no reason
just do some just do some farming
just do some farming in minecraft and
then you'll get out of this
minecraft made in sweden no need to
thank me
you are welcome 90 day
fiance couples be like please please
uh girls waking up boys waking up
that face what even am i looking at
what even am i looking at i'm scared 20
20 december 31 2359
2020 december 31 23 60.
then the this year will never end huh
megalovania starts playing
oh you thought it was sober this isn't
even my final form
i turned myself into a male in marzia oh
my god that's hilarious
that's the funniest [ __ ] i've ever
[ __ ] seen man
what if pickle rick was never funny at
all what if it was all a dream
lover hit love him or hate him he do
do do do do do
do do do do do do do do do do do do do
do
i get it because i watch fitness and
ferb and i understand
all the avatar references as well no one
the camera angle in anime when the
character is about to go
insane absolute
sicko mode how do you even do that must
have been sim
no no um
was that cool oh god i got a headache ah
why did i do that
no no hey look it's aang
that's so cool i heard you guys like
dragon ball so my god
god damn it i made one mistake
one tiny mistake it was pixel art
i didn't look i'm sorry
i 3d printed tambourine that goes on the
back of my pewdiepie
that's so cool very huge
large dick bruh you should uh
you should leave the thing so other
people can print it what's the
schematics bro
oh he did he didn't share it or she
that's so cool
what you never played tuber
simulator [ __ ] download it
it's free and it happened flipping
relevant
jesus christ it got censored because of
nipples
seriously classic
beards waiting for the tambourines to
arrive might say who canceled the order
no no i can't do that voice
no there can't be two different chats
from two different planes of existence
you look good yes
yes yes yes yes i didn't i didn't mean
that meme
i wanted to give me this chin and that
hair
all right that's all i want i mean
there's there's no editing obviously
huh who's the chad now y'all a bunch of
betas
if your chin is not as big as an iron
board then you nothing
that you bail another intro oh
hell yeah
nice city oh she tweeted oh epic
to all those thinking it's my kids chair
i'm 19 year old
and you don't even know if math is
related to science
nice
mad lady mad ass that's awesome
no that's disgusting what the hell never
ow once you flow again you're floating
for laughs
never never this happen photos that
radiate the same energy
epic pewterman maya enters during a
video oh dear oh dear gorgeous fears
when endear enters
donkey edgar's been trying to steal the
tambourine from me
i got proof i heard a snore and the
tambourine dazzle i look down beneath me
this is what i see can you even see this
you see this he's trying to hit the
tambourine
no you can't just hit tambourine you're
a dog
are you winning son my dad made this for
me for my 16th birthday that's so sweet
double tambourine that's epic don't
don't make it bigger than mine though
that's illegal that's a legal ninja
goddamn knew it
goddammit hey look it's aang i see him
yeah
hey that's so cool damn
she did you dirty edgar god damn that's
a thick boy
very cool very peepy nice
wait it's all sweden always has been
i told you bro i told you about the
sweden bro
someone had to do it nice yes yes yes
yes yes
yes oh we got another jojo
that's my that's my right there
we need a manly version of the pewdiepie
not the kid version
[Music]
drew pewdiepie versus coca melon in
dragon ball style
now that's uh airbender last avatar i've
seen that anime
many times so i i would know all these
buildings are better than anything i've
ever built
the fanbase he built i stand by my
statement
tambourine gang no mercy
[Music]
[Applause]
nice nice nice nicer
[Music]
factually correct meme very huge
dieck very luck yeah
congratulations pewdiepie with 100
million subscribers from internet
explorer team oh
thank you microsoft thank you so much
other people's dads you guys mean the
world to me
my dad you're nothing you understand
yeah this is basically what i said in
live stream i'm sorry
too far how a single swedish submarine
defeated the u.s navy
no need to thank me i was literally
about to say that
if it's in 2017 i take full
responsibility
that i made controversy bubbling racist
appears in 2020 interact with my
audience and motivate creativity
through my subreddit without spreading
hate hell yeah
oh floor gang always 2017 pewdiepie
wait it's floor gang always has been see
i did the meme guys i'm part of the kids
crew
i have the most sims no i do amateurs
you thought it was might say but it was
me do you agree i'd simply
any second my god
it's assembling yes jojo
bizarre adventure confirmed swedish
you're welcome
no need to thank me
we were first to put men into space usa
we were first to put man on the moon
ireland
we helped
we helped guys
potatoes yes
life size representation
replication i told you bro i told you
the head size is also the same at least
the size of my ego
actually not big enough i work for a
foster group home and today i made the
kids felix hot dogs oh i hope they liked
it
nice nice nice very wholesome
i like like like south africa who did
the first heart transplant
sweden who invented the cream separator
you're welcome for the cream separator
guys
actually i retract all my apologies
sweden invented the creams a b
cream separator so i deserve some
goddamn respect i'm allowed to snap at
you guys sometimes okay
but i'm sorry anyway for some reason
all right that's this week's little lie
hope you enjoyed thanks for watching
i know i wouldn't be here without you
guys and i it's important to remember
that
so i am sorry see you next time
hey ah children of
nine parts it's time to raise what was
once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big
pp pre-order promotion i mean